I remain committed to the courses
possible cooperation collaboration and
alignment and let me stress again as I
have done so many times before I have no
interest whatsoever in politics when it
comes to tackling this virus it is
perfectly consistent with an overall
four nations approach to have a
pragmatic acceptance that we may move at
different speeds if the evidence tells
us that that is necessary and I believe
we do now have that acceptance but
genuine consultation and alignment of
messages even perhaps especially when
the evidence is putting us on slightly
different timelines remains really
important we should not be reading of
each other's plans for the first time in
newspapers and decisions that are being
taken for one nation only for good
evidence-based reasons should not be
presented as if they apply uk-wide
clarity of message is paramount if we
expect all of you to know exactly what
it says we are asking of you and as
leaders we have a duty to deliver that
clarity to those we are accountable to
not to confuse it to that end I have
asked the UK government not to deploy
their stay alert advertising campaign in
Scotland because the message in Scotland
at this stage is not stay at home if you
can the messages except for the
essential reasons you know about stay at
home full-stop fundamentally we all have
a responsibility and it is a very heavy
one for all of us to make decisions and
set policies based on our own data of
what is safe and what is not I am clear
as First Minister that for Scotland at
this present moment relaxing too many
restrictions too quickly creates a real
risk that the virus will take off again
and I am not prepared to take that risk
that is why except for the fact that
from tomorrow you can go out to exercise
more than once a day
the current lockdown restrictions remain
in place I very much hope that it would
be possible to lift more of them in the
days and weeks ahead and as I've set out
already we are making plans for that